part b
using correct units explain the meaning
of the definite integral so it's
definitely go from zero from t equals
zero to t equals 40 of the absolute
value of v of t
dt in the context of the problem
approximate the value of that integral
using a right riemann sum with the four
sub-intervals indicated in the table
all right so let's first tackle the
first part so what's the meaning of this
definite integral
so the velocity velocity is a is a
vector it has direction and you could
see when you look up here that sometimes
the velocity is positive and sometimes
it is negative and the reason a
reasonable interpretation of that is
well this is when she's walking in one
direction and then that's where that
whatever direction we
we assume is the positive direction and
this is when she's walking the other way
and so she she's she has a positive
velocity here and then she has a
negative velocity she has some speed in
the other direction and then she has a
positive velocity again so if you were
to take the absolute value of this if
you just cared about the magnitude of
the velocity what we're talking about
we're talking about speed
but we're not just talking about the
absolute value velocity we're
integrating the absolute value of
velocity over time from time equals zero
to time equals 40. so if you integrate
speed if you're saying okay for every
for every
little amount of time dt she has some
speed well that's going to give you the
distance that she travels so the
distance remember is the difference
between distance and displacement is
displacement you can think of as the net
distance it takes if you go back and
forth a bunch of times it's going to add
up to the distance but they're going to
net out with with respect to each other
in displacement so this right over here
is going to give us the total distance
not displacement that she trapped that
she travels over those 40 minutes if
there was no absolute value sign here
then we'd be talking about the
displacement and so let me write that so
this integral from 0 to 40 absolute
value v of t
dt
is
the
total
distance
she travels
over the 40 minutes over the 40
over the 40 minutes remember our unit of
time here is in minutes
all right
so using correct units and so this is
and so the units
let me write it this way
is the total distance she travels over
the 40 minutes
the units are meters
the units
are
meters
all right
then they say approximate the value of
that integral using a right riemann sum
with the four sub intervals indicated in
the table so what do they mean by a
right riemann sum
well actually let me just let me just
draw let me draw the absolute value of v
of t and i already took the trouble in
the last part of drawing the axes and
you wouldn't actually have to do this on
the test but i'm doing this to just help
you
understand what we're actually going to
do when we talk about a right riemann
sum so if we so in orange i have v of t
but if i want to do the absolute value
of v of t i'll do that in magenta so the
absolute value of that is that absolute
value of that is that absolute value of
that is that absolute value of negative
220 is going to be positive 220. so we
saw here when time when t is equal to 24
v of t is negative 220. she's running in
the opposite direction or jogging in the
other direction but we're going to take
the absolute value of that
so when t
is equal to 24
her speed we could say
is going to be 220 we take the absolute
value of it so it's going to be right
around
right around there and then the absolute
value of this is going to be that point
again
and so we don't know the actual velocity
function the actual velocity function i
don't know it might look something like
it might look something like like this
it goes like that maybe it dips down or
i should say the speed function we don't
know the actual speed function this so
this is the absolute value of v of t
which is the speed function you could
say
speed
function
and so if we wanted to actually
integrate it so we if we wanted to
integrate it well we don't know how to
do it if we don't know we don't know how
to do it exactly without knowing the
exact function but we can approximate
what the integral is going to be with a
right riemann sum and a riemann sum is
just breaking up this area into
rectangles and then finding the total
area of those rectangles and then
there's a couple of ways you could do it
you could use you could use
for each rectangle you could use the
left boundary as the height or you could
use the right boundary as the height and
so they tell us to use a right riemann
sum
a right riemann sum so for each of the
rectangles for each of the intervals
we're going to use the value of our
function on the right side to
approximate the area so let's do that
so let me divide this into four
rectangles and they give us the four
intervals
so
one interval goes from zero to t equals
twelve
we see that there the other interval
goes from twelve to twenty the next
interval goes from twenty to twenty four
the next interval goes from twenty four
to forty and the whole notion of a
riemann sum is completely foreign to you
i encourage you to watch the videos on
khan academy on riemann sums
and so
here we are so the first interval is
from 0 to 12. and so we want to use the
value of our function on the right side
to define the height of the rectangle
so let me define so that rectangle is
going to look
is going to look like
this
so that's a rectangle right over there
then the next interval goes from 12 to
the next rectangle goes from 12 to 20.
we see that there from 12 to 20. so
let's use the value of our function at
20 to define the height of this
rectangle
so just like that
look like
let me do it you just hand draw that it
would look
like
that
and then the next rectangle goes from t
equals 20 to t equals 24 and we want to
use the right hand side to define the
height of that rectangle
you can see it's a little irregular and
that's okay they all don't have to have
the same width
so the height is something like this
and then
the last interval is t equals 24 to t
equals 40. and so we use the right side
as the height
so the interval so this was the last
interval we did the next interval is
going to be that
and then the height we use the right
hand side
to define the height that's why it's a
right riemann sum and so our
approximation of the integral of the
absolute value of v of t is going to be
the area of these rectangles over here
and so
we could write
the integral from 0 to 40 of the
absolute value of v of t
dt
is
approximately what's going to be this
first change in time times this height
so this first change in time this is a
change in time of 12
times it's going to be 12
times
what's the height well v of 12
we knew was 200
v of 12 is 200
so it's going to be 12 times
12 times 200
plus
okay the height here or the next
interval goes from 12 to 20. so it's
going to be eight times and then the
height here is going to be what is v of
20 i think that was v of 20 was 240
v of 20 was 240
and then the next interval goes from 20
to 24. so that only has a change in time
of four
and then what is the height at
24 the height at 24. and remember we
took the absolute value of e of t so
it's 220.
so 4 times 220
and then our last rectangle our change
in time we go from 24 to 24 to 40 so our
change in time is 16
times the height at 40 what was that
that was 150 i think yep that was a 150
so times 150
and so just to make clear what i just
did i'm just adding up the sums of the
areas of these rectangles the area of
this rectangle is 12 times 200 area of
this rectangle is 8 times 240 the area
of this rectangle is 4 times 220 area of
this rectangle is 16 times 150 and then
let's see we could calculate that we're
not allowed to use our calculator for
this part so we're going to do it by
hand 12 times 200 is going to be 2400
plus
8 times 240 that's going to be 1600
1600 plus 3200 that is 19
20. did i do that right 8 times 40 is
3200 or sorry 8 times 40 is 320 plus
1600 yup that's right
plus this is going to be
plus
let's see 15 times 15 is going to be
would be 2250 that would be 15 times 150
and so we're going to have another 150
and so this is going to be 2400
whoops
2400. now we want to add all these
together let me just do it the way that
the easiest way 2400 plus
1920 plus 880
plus
plus 2400 again
plus 2400 again will give us
will give us we get a 0
we get a 10.
so let's see we have 9 plus 9 is 18
plus 8 is
26. and then we have seven
so we get seven thousand six hundred so
is equal to seven thousand
six
hundred and just to be clear our this is
would be in meters in
in meters
in meters now you might be saying wait
wait didn't we just find an area
wouldn't areas be in meters squared but
remember we're not we're finding the
area under the velocity under the
velocity graph and so if you look at our
units say for this rectangle right here
you're multiplying
12 minutes
you're multiplying 12 minutes times
times 200 meters per minute times 200
meters per
minute so when you multiply them out the
minutes cancel with the minutes and
you're left with 2400 meters so even
though it's area if you look at the the
units it's going to be in meters not
meters squared